bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
nous allons parler d'auto organisation
et de comportements collectifs petits
messages préventifs relais des
physiciens de bordeaux ont étudié le
comportement de petit cafard mécanique
comme celui ci ce sont des jouets pour
enfants en plastique muni de dix petites
pâtes molles et d'une petite batterie
leur corps vibre ce qui engendre un
déplacement globalement en ligne droite
avec de petites variations de direction
les chercheurs ont étudié comment
s'organiser un groupe de plus en plus
grand de ces petites bêtes mécaniques
lorsqu on les place dans une enceinte
fermée de 60 cm de diamètre exactement
comme des cafards coincés au fond de
votre poubelle
lorsque les cafards mécaniques sont peu
nombreux il bouge dans tous les sens et
ne s'accumulent pas il adopte ainsi un
comportement que l'on qualifie de gaz
oui un gaz de cafard mécanique est là
j'aurais jamais cru dire un truc comme
ça
disons qu'ils se comportent comme les
molécules dans un gaz
mais quand on augmente le nombre de
robots cafard un étrange phénomène se
produit
regardez dans cette expérience on en a
120 soit deux fois plus que dans la
première vidéo alors qu'au centre
on observe bien toujours l'agitation
dans gagnent on voit que certains se
massent bien alignés face à la paroisse
vous trouvez pas qu'il ya un petit côté
malesan même si on sait que ce ne sont
pas des vrais blatt
donc à partir d'un nombre critique de
cafard mécanique 70 environ
on observe une transition vers un régime
stable ou deux états coexistant le gaz
les cafards au mieux et les agrégats les
cafards autour de la paroisse et cette
observation est en accord avec leurs
théories comme on peut le voir sur cette
simulation
ceci est un modèle purement informatique
du comportement de particules de même
taille et de même vitesse que nos cafard
mécanique
elle se déplace globalement en ligne
droite avec des variations aléatoires à
gauche avec 60 particules et à droite
avec son vin et maintenant si on lâche
et les cafards
lorsqu'on place des cafards dans une
enceinte mobile et flexible et ils
forment très vite des agrégats même avec
seulement une dizaine de cafard ces
agrégats pousse la paroisse et
permettent de la déplacer et ils
arrivent à traverser un trou
[Musique]
et même contourner un obstacle allez
vas-y tu dégages mais nous voulons
montrer
je rappelle ici qu'il s'agit de jouets
mécaniques sans communication entre eux
et sans aucune coordination globale
je sais pas si cette réflexion rend la
chose plus rassurante ou plus flippante
ces recherches montrent donc l'émergence
d'une auto organisation à partir
d'éléments indépendants très simple et
ce type de dispositif ouvre la voie à de
nombreuses applications dans le
nettoyage ou l'exploration
car les mini robots arrive à se déplacer
entre les obstacles et dans des espaces
très étroit par exemple il pourrait
accomplir des tâches comme la
dépollution au milieu dangereux
voilà donc je vous laisse sur cette note
positive parce que on peut le dire
cette recherche elle ne donne pas le
cafard
est ce lui max se veut un ouais c'est
trop bien je reviens la poubelle de
s'associant à c'est trop cool
oui oui vas-y abonne toi ou est d'accord
je vais me poser